All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
The first one, very, very ripe for people
both
have been very angry with me.
The question is, Hey David, why are you ignoring
Tulsi Gabard all the time?
Which is just so funny because I, I talk about
Tulsi Gabard as much as I talk about any of
the other one percenters.
Uh, except I'd say Andrew Yang because Andrew
Yang has been on our show three times.
Tulsi is welcome anytime and I'd be glad to
interview her on the program.
I talked about Marianne Williamson a little
bit after the second debate because I thought
she actually did notably well in that debate,
but still big picture, especially after finding
out that she was, uh, offering new age woo
stuff to her campaign list, which is crazy.
I mean, she's just another one of these one
percenters that's going nowhere.
The problem I don't think is that I am talking
about Tulsi Gabbert not enough.
She's basically getting the same attention
from me as the other zero to one percenters
who are not going to last much longer.
The problem is that there is a cult of personality
around Tulsi that makes people see that.
When I don't talk about Amy Klobuchar or I
don't talk about Kirsten Gillibrand, it doesn't
warrant emails to me or complaints or any
kind of investigation into what my biases
are, but not talking about Tulsi.
There definitely is something going on there.
This is again what I was talking about a couple
of weeks ago when I said I sort of self-censor
on some issues because there no upside and
in this case it's not even that it's, there's
no specific focus or lack of focus on Tulsi
on this program.
There are lots of people in my audience who
see everything through Tulsi colored glasses.
I guess I would say where when I do talk about
Tulsi Gabard, if it's anything short of completely
glowing and everything is just so amazing
that Tulsi does, I'm some kind of, you know,
anti Tulsi shill or democratic this or that.
Who even knows what the argument is.
If I don't talk about Tulsi, the absence of
discussions of Tulsi are what is the problem
even though I'm also barely talking about
any of the other candidates that are, uh,
polling zero to one or zero to one and a half.
So this is an example of what I was talking
about.
No matter what I do, if I talk about her in
anything but the most glowing terms, if I
don't talk about her no matter what, I'm clearly
doing something wrong.
Let me say it in completely clear terms.
I have no particular favor or disfavor for
Tulsi Gabard compared to John Delaney or Hickenlooper
or Marianne Williamson or whoever.
I mean, okay.
I find the new age guru stuff weird with Marianne
Williamson.
I see Tulsi Gabbert as a candidate who like
all of the candidates, I can find things I
agree with her.
On.
There are things I disagree on, but I basically
pay attention to her in proportion to what
I believe is the appropriate amount of attention
that should be paid and given that she is
pulling zero to one and a half percent, given
that she is not done particularly well in
the debates, given that she's not come up
with any particularly interesting policy,
for example, the way that I think Andrew Yang
has, that's all it is.
I'm just talking about her in proportion to
how important I think she is in this race.
You can disagree with me about that.
You can tell me David.
No, here's why Tulsi really is the person
that even though she's polling zero to one,
like all these other people, you should be
talking about way more than we can have a
conversation, but just saying, David, the
fact that you are quote, ignoring Tulsi Gabbert
is the problem.
This is laughable.
This is the exact cult of personality stuff
that I've been talking about when I talk about
all of these issues that if you don't say
the right thing, there is a sliver of the
left that will absolutely go crazy and attack
you.